quasi die lukb pizza 3.0 60 mal gingen
die migräne werfen nach freunde di luca
pizza zwei von vier tagen raus gekommen
viele nachrichtenportale haben darüber
artikel geschrieben und auch viele
youtuber haben dazu reviews hochgeladen
außerdem bei unser video auf dem rewe
kanal platz 1 in den trend und ist auch
jetzt nach drei vier tagen noch immer
platz drei in den trend ich hab grad
fast mein monitor vom tisch gelegt auf
jeden fall für eure enormen krasses
feedback zur luca pizza meine damen und
herren sie schmeckt mega geil ich bin
überglücklich allerdings gibt es auch
einige hater und auf die reagiere ich
heute fehlt bereits im titel
eingeblendet ansage hand tanzverbot
darauf werde ich gleich einen gehen
allerdings erstmal auf einige kommentare
die unter dem rewe video gepostet wurden
wohl eine stinknormale schinken pizza
die mit farbstoffen gefüllt ist damit
sie schwarz ist
hast du hier um was drin in der pizza
befindet sich pflanzliche aktivkohle um
die ganze pizza bekömmlicher zu machen
also damit man sie besser verträgt die
cetera pp und das färbt hat unter
anderem schwarz ganzen kohle ist
allerdings ein natürlicher farbstoff aus
der natur der niederlanden
natur also da jetzt nichts chemisches
künstliches trainer oder irgendwas
anderes als ich nicht was mich da
geritten hat einfach kein gefährt und
auf preis gerechtfertigt marketing at
its best erstmal heißt es in dem
zusammenhang ist also als englisch
nachhilfe braucht kontaktiere mich gern
außerdem kostete die luca pizza 13 eur
49 unter mir im revier nebenan kostet di
luca pizza zwei gerade 39 40 genau
gleich viel ich kann es allerdings
natürlich verstehen wenn jemand sagt hey
drei euro 49 ist mir zu teuer für seine
riesige pizza da kauf ich mir lieber für
70 cent was anderes ich mein ich wollte
einfach etwas machen auf das nicht
selber stolz bin und da bin ich ganz
ehrlich da verkaufe ich lieber was für
ein euro mehr als das ich da nicht
wirklich komplett hinter stehe ich würde
es so hart feiern würde der andere tut
da sagen die pizzas aber irgendwie schon
widerlegt dass man keinen scheiß meine
allergrößte angst während dieses videos
dass wir da gedreht haben
ich hatte die spitze zu dem zeitpunkt
schon gegessen allerdings hat die person
der moderator noch nicht gegessen und
ich hatte richtig angst ist also echt
scheiße findet aber er mochte sie und
auch alle leute hinter der kamera also
alles kugel ab in die trends gekauft wie
sind kommentar habe ich so gott verdammt
häufig bekommen zusammen oft auch mit
dem kommentar gut gemacht rewe schöne
die trends in platz eins gebootet
allerdings erstmal an alle leute die
mich jetzt fragen hey luca was heißt
denn gepostet oder gekauft in bezug auf
youtube ihr seht daran dass ein video
sage ich mal dass da was gekauft wurde
beispielsweise wenn es sehr sehr viele
aufrufe hat die beispielsweise 450.000
dagegen dann allerdings nur so 20
kommentare oder 99 likes daran sieht man
einfach dass das video organisch
überhaupt nicht gewachsen ist und man da
einfach preview anzeigen gekauft hat so
dass das video views bekommen bei
unserem live video allerdings fast eine
halbe million aufrufe 25.000 mehr
über 3000 kommentare das ist organisch
so gewachsen dass ward nur ihr also
danke für euer krankes feedback auf dem
video ist halt nicht mehr werbung drauf
deswegen übrig sich noch direkte
kommentar jetzt ist er auch im youtube
business und streckt auf zehn minuten
als zehn minuten videos kann man halt
mehr werbung schalten auf youtube aber
das macht keinen sinn wenn auf dem
ganzen video endlich machen keine
werbung ist das ist halt so gespielt um
werbung für die luca pizza
na klar ist dass werbung für di luca
pizza was ist was soll das auch sonst
seien bei mir ist die pizza nicht im
revier habe nachgefragt aber die meinten
die kommt erst mit frühestens das ist
ein kommentar den ich auch sehr häufig
bekommen habe und zwar liegt das ganz
einfach daran dass viele rewe und edeka
märkte die pizza jetzt bestellt haben
und sie deswegen erst später kommen tut
mir leid aber wir können leider nichts
an den bestell gewohnheiten von herr
manfred in kiel ändern gibt es die
pizzen auch bei edeka ich hatte halt
ohne kooperation mit dem revier sind
selbstverständlich mit der pizza auch
bei edeka gelöst wird ganz geschickt von
lukas kanal zum kanal von rewe
umgeleitet ganz schlecht wer hat das
erst auch nicht gemerkt ja natürlich
habe ich von meinem video auf den
revier kann also was herr was ist daran
schlitten mit deutschland geht es nicht
bergab weil die afg zulegt sondern weil
die menschen so etwas schauen die person
setzt eine rechtsradikale partei gleich
mit mir einem jungen der die pizza haus
bringt also ich weiß nicht was mit
deiner weltanschauung kaputt allerdings
habe ich dann auf twitter einen tweet
gesehen der an den youtuber tanzverbot
gesendet wurde und zwar doppelt peas und
ein bild von der verpackung der pizza wo
ich doppelpass zeige daraufhin hat
tanzverbot geantwortet doppeltief ist
eine eingetragene marke von mir und ich
werde jetzt gucken was ich dagegen
unternehmen kann ich habe das gesehen
und habe erstmal abgewartet und geschaut
wir das ganze so weiter vor sich geht
und dann hat tatsächlich ein bild von
seiner urkunde über die eintragung der
marke doppel peace gepostet fand ich
dann halt auch nützlich dass er erst
geschrieben hat doppel peace ist eine
eingetragene marke auf seiner urkunde
steht allerdings doppelpass zusammen
geschrieben also seine eigene marke
falsch geschrieben wer uns halt bei der
produktion des kartons gedacht hey ich
mache fünf verschiedene posen wie
beispielsweise denen hier oder wenn ich
traurig bin weil ich keine pizza oder
unter anderem auch doppel peace weil ich
dachte hey das ist lustig vielleicht
freut sich tanzverbot ein kanal video
darüber waren noch als tanzverbot an auf
twitter wirklich ein bisschen
ausgerastet ist und meinte hey was kann
ich denn jetzt dagegen unternehmen und
keine ahnung was muss ich mal eben ganz
kurz vor zwischen gerät schon haben uns
selbstverständlich vorher informiert und
tanzverbot hat nicht in der klasse pizza
die marke doppel pisa eingetragen
sondern nur ein klasse 9 25 und 32
hitzer ist glaube ich gebäck und das ist
unter 30 oder 31
einfach mal rum stressen ohne grund er
meinte weiter hinaus dass er sich mit
seinem anwalt zusammensetzen und dann
mal schauen was man da machen kann kann
ich an der stelle schon mal sagen ihr
könnt nichts machen wir lieber kilian
ich kann dir ein paar pizzen zukommen
lassen
wenn du hunger hast dann hoffe ich dass
das damit geklärt ist bittet an anderer
stelle fand es dann allerdings auch
lustig dass der liebe nette super
journalisten newstime dazu direkt ein
video hochgeladen hat sondern man ganz
aktuell gibt es eine auseinandersetzung
zwischen dem youtuber tanzverbot und
kontrakte
erst einmal warum auseinandersetzung das
erste mal dass ich etwas dazu sage es
jetzt gerade
ich habe also bisher nur tanzverbot
irgendwas getwittert eine ahnung woher
newstime eine reaktion daher nahm aber
okay wir vielleicht mitbekommen habt hat
der youtuber converter gemeinsam mit dem
rewe-supermarkt eine neue pizza
herausgebracht ich habe die pizza nicht
mit rewe rausgebracht und mit gustavo
gusto wo holst du dir deine
informationen her das wort doppelt peace
ist ein geschützter begriff von
tanzverbot wow
er blendet man screenshot ein diesem
screenshot wo doppelpass auseinander
geschrieben wie er das ist kein
geschützter begriff und hans von crafter
ist ja für den satz bekannt zitat ich
hab das wird meine medien anwältin
abgeklärt inwieweit das nun mit seinen
medien anwältin abgeklärt wurde ist noch
ganz offen
das nichts offen
als vorher abgeklärt und wir sind auf
der sicheren seite und ob daraus dann
schlussendlich ein rechtsstreit wir
zwischen tanzverbot und concept das ist
noch komplett offen da ist gar nix offen
weil daraus nichts passieren kann kommt
macht das selber hat sich hierzu bisher
noch nicht zu wort gemeldet das nicht
besonders schlag er sagt zu beginn hey
ya wir eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
tanzverbot und kontraste und am ende
sagt er dann ja kundschaft hat sich dazu
noch gar nicht zu wort gemeldet justin
bieber ich hasse dich gibt
auseinandersetzungen justin bieber und
kontraste also ich weiß nicht was er mit
diesem video bezwecken wollte er ist
halt ne news kanal und wahrscheinlich
haben sich die nachrichten mal wieder
überschlagen schickt mir gerne deine
adresse dann lasst ihren pizzen zu
kommen italien kommen wir nun allerdings
zu einem preview video was nicht sehr
sehr sehr unterhaltsam fand ich würde
sagen wir schauen einfach direkt mal
rein
4 dass ich direkt und kopf gebissen er
hat im supermarkt die letzte luca pizza
entdeckt und hat den preis gesehen 4 eur
49 ich weiß auch nicht also ein paar
märkte haben die pizza für 349 euro
notiert jetzt muss jeder markt für sich
selbst entscheiden haben wir leider
keinen einfluss drauf er denn das video
luca pizza 2 review da irgendwie sowas
geht in supermarkt wie die pizza und
sagt hey die lasse ich hier die es mir
zu teuer ich keine andere steht im
steinofen gebacken
scheiß auf steinhofen heute in dem guten
wetter einfach mal sagen macht der
crafter und holt sich dann so in kleiner
form natürlich wie machte überhaupt eure
pizza also ich würde sagen aus wie die
von luca ist quasi die lückenbüßer 3.0
und ist mit 23 gewissen form aber das
ist das unterhaltsamste video weil sie
in den letzten tage auf you tube gesehen
habe habe ich natürlich und in der
beschreibung verlinkt an gab es noch ein
anderes video was ich auch sehr denn als
21 dort ein youtuber für
euro luca pizzen gekauft so wir sind
jetzt im resistenter angekommen als
spitze so hart von apparatur hierher
nice alter wirklich jeder interessiert
sich für den schweizer also leute das
hier sind alle luca pizzen dieses
komplett im rewe center gibt ich brauche
bei der kassiererin vorne noch hin hab
gefragt ob die noch ein paar im lager
haben aber hatten die leider auch nicht
er hat einfach alle luca pitzl aus dem
rewe center gekauft und dann kriege ich
die kommentare von anderen hey warum
gibt es die pizza hier bei mir nicht
mehr auf so was muss man erstmal kommen
jetzt geht es noch mal den standard rewe
hier gibt es sogar noch eine pizza
die nehme ich auch noch mit unseren
aktionspreis easy verkauft nicht nur dem
rewe center alles sehr sondern auch noch
dem underdog kaufte er sich die letzte
pizza weil er ja auch erst irgendwie 20
30 stück hat sie sind jetzt alle pizzen
die wir haben 100 sind echt extrem
wieder also das sind jetzt zu 100 euro
pizzen 100 euro
bist du noch zu retten danke auf jeden
fall für dein feedback zur pizza und
eine review m hat mich auf jeden fall
sehr sehr gefreut das video haben zu
schauen ich fand's es unterhaltsam auch
mit einem kollegen noch am ende habe ich
euch natürlich auch in der beschreibung
unten verlinkt es gibt noch so unfassbar
krass viele weitere videos zu luca pizza
2 auf youtube ein kühles bier ob wird
sie glaube ich zitieren in dem video
sturm hatte mir aufgeschrieben max und
ich habe überlegt ob wir so ein
wettessen machen also wenn ihr das wollt
dann das game ein like dann schreibt uns
und in die kommentare ich kann nicht auf
alle reviews eingehen weil ich in der
roda teil jetzt schon bei 38 minuten
allerdings habe ich mir noch vier fünf
weitere videos rausgesucht und das ein
bisschen was zusammengeschnitten also
hier seht ihr noch ein zwei drei vier
andere reviews finden haben wir übrigens
auch mega geil wieder so einen text also
die verpackung ist wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr geil geil wie einige von euch
wissen mag ich reiße heute kommt die low
carb heraus ich habe doch gar nicht erst
mal ein depp ist natürlich schmeckt
neutral und sieht vor allem auch heftig
lied aus noch nie hast du alle
tiefkühlpizza so heißgeliebte gott ich
habe nicht gehört dass das jetzt umluft
oder ist das jetzt umso hallo mein name
ist luca und ich liebe es nicht
[Musik]
wie lange ich war okay ich merke schon
wieder einen echten schaufenster
schneider sieht aus wie die eigentlich
nicht kaputtmachen dieser karton ist
echt schön alt einfach viel zu groß
jetzt habe ich jetzt wirklich noch nie
in meinem leben gesehen alter schwede
also leute weiterhin vergesst nicht was
das moderieren woran erkennt man dass
die verbreitet auch nicht mehr so lang
sind alle der teig schmeckt wirklich
minimal besser als kein
geschmacksunterschied wie es halt auch
beschrieben wurde
ich möchte ich mich sehr sehr gut hier
seht ihr dass der teig das ist einfach
mal richtig schwarz die schmeckt
wirklich schmeckt wirklich gut
geschmeckt mega k
die soffin wird der mega gedanke auf
jeden fall für euer enormen krasses
feedback mich hat sehr gefreut eure
ganzen videos dazu anzuschauen
es gab wirklich bisher keine person die
gesagt hat haye die schmeckt echt
scheiße die meisten leute meinen halt
irgendwie so ok man muss sich daran
gewöhnen dass sie jetzt so wirklich
schwarz ist aber sie schmeckt dadurch
nicht anders die schmeckt einfach wie
eine stinknormale schinken pizza
prosciutto ich saß hier wirklich mit so
einem dauergrinsen und dafür die ganzen
videos angeschaut das war sehr sehr sehr
sehr schön ich freue mich dass die
deutsche kicker ich hab gerade micro
geschlagen ich freue mich auf jeden fall
ultra dass euch die pizza so gefällt wie
gesagt sie gibt es im rewe und edeka und
im heutigen video wollte ich einfach auf
ein paar sachen reagieren ansage an
tanzverbot nicht unnötig was raus wenn
du nichts zu belegen hast also wir haben
uns wirklich vorher abgesichert so dass
wir dich dann nicht irgendwie angehen
oder rechtlich wir uns in irgendwie weiß
ich nicht dann duellieren müssen oder so
wie gesagt ich kann dir gern pizzen zu
schicken lukas weber instagram direct
einfach deine adresse zu schicken
natürlich 14.20 pizzen dann kannst du
vielleicht auch wieder darüber machen
wie du sie bewertet ist würde ich mich
auf jeden fall sehr darüber freuen
nochmal an euch leute danke schön dass
die videos bisher alle so krass für euch
ankamen dass rewe video wie gesagt das
ist jetzt seit drei vier tagen auf platz
1 in den trends was ist so übel mehr
brauche ich jetzt allerdings gar nicht
sagen wer durch das video hier gefallen
hat lassen leichter wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent sind noch kein teil der lupus
liegt unter dem video auf abonnieren und
jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]